MALE SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, everybody.
I have the esteemed pleasure of
introducing our guest speaker
today.
Dr. Jeffery A. Lieberman is
the Lawrence C. Cole Professor
and Chairman of Psychiatry
at the Columbia University
College of Physicians
and Surgeons,
Director of the New York
State Psychiatric Institute,
and Psychiatrist in Chief
of New York Presbyterian
Hospital at the Columbia
University Medical Center.
Formally the President of
the American Psychiatric
Association, in
2000 he was elected
to the National Academy of
Sciences Institute of Medicine.
He lives with his
wife in New York City,
and Rosemary is
here today as well.
Without further
ado, Dr. Lieberman.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFFREY LIEBERMAN:
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE],
and good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for coming.
A pleasure to be here.
My first time visiting
the Google Campus.
And I'm here to give a talk, but
it's really to promote my book.
And I give a lot of
lectures to all types
of professional or
scientific groups,
and periodically to
lay audiences, as well.
But this is really
the first time doing
sort of a book promotion talk.
And in the course
of my career-- which
has been 30-plus years in
the field of psychiatry,
and mostly sort of in
academic psychiatry--
I've written many articles--
hundreds of articles
for the scientific literature
and a bunch of books
for a professional audience, but
never for the general public.
This was the first
one that I did.
So first thing I'd like to
say is that the title of it,
"Shrinks: The Untold Story of
Psychiatry," was not my idea.
I'll tell you what
led me to write
the book in the first place.
When I first decided
that I was going
to do a book for
the general audience
and was developing
a proposal, my agent
got a publisher who was very
interested in this topic
and I went to see her.
And I told her about the
book and she said, well,
what are you calling it?
And I said, well, I was
thinking of something--
and I wanted to come
up with something
which was poetic and eloquent.
I was thinking along
the lines of "Pariahs
in the Palace of Medicine"
or "Sojourn in the Scientific
Wilderness."
And she looks at me
and she says, mm-mm.
That's not going to work.
And I said, what do
you Think She says,
just give me a couple of days.
So she took the proposal, or
what I had of it at the time,
and she sort of shopped it
around in terms of the office
and calls me up and
says, I got your title.
I said, what is it?
She says, it's "Shrinks: The
Untold Story of Psychiatrists."
I said, shrinks?
They can't use that.
She says, why not?
I said, well, it's kind
of demeaning, isn't it?
She said, but that's what
everybody thinks about when
they think about psychiatry.
It's the most common reference.
So do you want to write a
book for your colleagues
or do you want to write a
book that a wider audience is
going to read?
Hence the title.
The cover wasn't my
idea, either-- a couch.
I wanted a brain with neural
circuits and all these things.
So, shows you how knowledge is
not necessarily transferable
across disciplines.
But the reason I wrote the
book was that-- I mean, I never
really had any aspirations
to write in this way,
to become TV doc or
write for the public.
But over the course
of my career--
30-plus years, mostly doing
research in the neurobiology
and psychopharmacology of
more severe mental disorders--
schizophrenia, bipolar
disorder, depression--
I became increasingly aware
and increasingly frustrated
by the fact that millions--
millions-- of people
suffer from mental illness,
experience their symptoms,
and don't avail themselves of
treatment for the simple reason
that either they are not aware
of what it is, because it's not
like when you have a belly
ache or you're short of breath
or you have some kind of
dysfunction in your urination
or elimination process.
They don't know,
or they're ashamed,
or they don't know how
to find competent care.
And the analogy
would be, imagine
if the American population
was experiencing
various types of
infectious diseases--
pneumonia, tuberculosis,
malaria, polio, AIDS-- and many
of the people who were sick
weren't getting antibiotics,
hadn't previously been
treated with vaccines,
and weren't offered, let's
say, protease inhibitors
or antiretrovirals because
there was suspicion
or ignorance out there.
Now, Jenny McCarthy
would probably
say that's probably
a good thing,
but I don't think many
people would agree with her.
But that is the case
for mental illness.
And so the question is
why is that the case.
And a simple reason
is that it's stigma.
So to put it very succinctly,
mental illnesses--
which I'll define for you in
a minute-- are nothing new.
They're not like chronic
fatigue syndrome,
they're not like
Ebola, they're not
like AIDS-- things that
are newly emergent.
These are illnesses
that have been
present since the beginning
of recorded history,
but they weren't
well understood.
Historically, it was
thought to be related
to demon possession or
supernatural phenomena,
or curses of the gods
or something like that.
And then in the
modern era-- beginning
in the late 18th,
early 19th centuries
when medical science
sort of began
to investigate the
pathologic bases of illness--
there really wasn't
much traction that
was able to be achieved
with mental disorders.
So there was always this
sort of mystery around it,
lack of understanding based
on scientific progress,
and there were no
treatments to speak of.
But all that changed, and
it changed very rapidly.
And the inflection
point was really
after World War II in the 1950s.
But even today, which is 65
years later, the attitudes
and the prejudices and
the ignorance associated
historically with mental
illness-- and by extension,
psychiatry-- continues.
Whereas if you had a mental
illness prior to 1950s,
there was nothing
that could really
be effective in treating you.
You were either doomed
to endure your symptoms
or, if they were really
bad and incapacitating
and you didn't have a family
that could support you,
you likely would spend some
extended period of time,
if not your whole life,
in a mental institution.
And that's because there just
wasn't anything available.
But now, the biggest barrier
to treatment for people
is not the lack of know-how
and the lack of treatments.
The biggest barrier
is simply the stigma.
And in this way, mental illness
and psychiatry are unique.
The best way to
illustrate that is
to tell you something you
probably already know,
which is that there is
a very active, virulent
anti-psychiatry movement.
Have you ever heard of an
anti-cardiology movement
or an anti-dermatology
movement, or
an anti-orthopedics movement?
There's an
anti-psychiatry movement,
and it actually
began in the 1960s.
So mental illness
and psychiatry has
been victimized in this way.
To put it in a humorous
way, psychiatry
is like the Rodney
Dangerfield of medicine.
It doesn't get any respect.
To put it in a more
sober way, it's
kind of the stepchild
of medicine.
It's been a late bloomer,
just like a sibling who's
the slowest to develop, who's
the runt of the litter, who's
the butt of jokes and maybe not
picked first to be on the team
and has low expectations
associated with it.
But in the long run
they end up being either
quite as accomplished and
capable as the other siblings,
or even surpass them
in some respects.
And that's basically
the story of psychiatry.
Now, you're listening to me
tell this and you're saying,
oh, he's a psychiatrist.
He's going to be sort
of tooting his own horn,
blowing his own horn,
and being self-serving.
But I have to tell you that I
don't think that's the case.
When I speak publicly
there's a lot of hecklers,
and there's a lot
of people who have--
I've just doing some radio
talk shows in San Francisco,
and you get a lot of really
nasty stuff that comes in.
And I doubt if cardiologists or
orthopedists or pediatricians
would get this.
People might disagree
or something.
So there's really strong
feelings and emotions
associated with this.
So let me just tell you first
what I mean by mental illness,
because there's a lot
of misconceptions.
Misconceptions abound.
Everybody's mentally
ill a little bit.
Schizophrenia is having
a split personality,
or holding two mutually
contradictory opinions
at the same time.
Mental illness is really
kind of freedom of expression
and not succumbing to the
oppressive conventions
of the world.
So, many misconceptions.
What's the difference between a
psychiatrist and psychologist?
There's many, many
misconceptions,
which basically have to do
with a lack of understanding
and awareness.
So for our purposes,
mental illness
is distinct from what
we'll call problems
of living in the worried well,
which everyone experiences
in the course of their life
because life is variable,
challenging, and
oftentimes tough.
But the human organism
is built to endure this,
unless they sustain
some injury or illness.
And the brain can get ill
just like every other organ
of the body.
So for the purpose,
mental illness
are really defined
set of conditions
that are related
ostensibly to dysfunctions
of certain parts of the brain
that mediate functions relating
to cognition, perception,
emotion regulation, information
storage, and processing, and can
be defined in a systematic way
and follow a fairly uniform
or predictable course.
So there's clear
boundaries, or definitions,
of what they are,
and there are clear
boundaries between
what's the variation
in human behavior and mental
states and what is an illness.
Now, we're not talking
about the worried well.
We're not talking about
problems of living.
And if you want to
make a distinction
right off the bat
between psychiatrist
and the rest of the mental
health care providers--
be they psychologists, social
workers, lay therapists,
pastoral counselors, clergyman,
new age practitioners--
is that psychiatrists deal
with so-called illnesses
of the brain manifest through
the mind and behavior,
and the others deal
with the aspects
that we face in the
course of our lives
that don't evolve or
develop into illnesses.
My purpose in
writing the book was
that it became
increasingly apparent
that many people weren't
being treated who should be,
and there was no good
reason for that other
than stigma and prejudice.
So I wanted to try
and put this out there
and set the record
straight about this.
And it seemed that I
was in a good position
to be able to do
it, because I had
had some success in terms
of my academic career
as a researcher.
I had gained some prominence
in terms of the profession
by becoming president of
the American Psychiatric
Association, and I had 30
years of clinical experience
on the ground.
And by virtue of my research,
I was sort of at a position
that I could understand
exactly what was happening
at the cutting edge
of progress, knowing
where things were going to go.
So I felt that I was in a
position to not just offer
opinion but to really synthesize
these different streams
of information.
And then there was
also another factor
that I thought made
me really well-suited
to this kind of task, which
was that just by dint of when
my parents met and
decided to do procreate,
I was born in a time that
landed me in medical school
at the time that psychiatry was
going through this inflection
point.
So remember, I told you
that in the 18th century
there were not specialties
like we have now.
Now we have like 40 different
sub specialties of medicine.
18th century there were
physicians and surgeons,
there were midwives,
there were bone doctors.
Neurology and psychiatry
differentiated as brain doctors
in the beginning of
the 19th century.
When the other fields, by
virtue of progress and research,
began to progress
and psychiatry didn't
after World War II
in the '50s, this
was the time when
really things begin
to move forward
scientifically speaking.
And that was largely
because of the introduction
of psychotropic
drugs, which came
about through pure
serendipity as opposed
to hypothesis-driven research.
But in any event,
this process which
began the '50s introducing
for the first time in history
treatments that actually worked
in form of medications that
could alleviate severe
illnesses-- not cure
them, but alleviate
the symptoms--
and then gained
momentum by virtue
of the advent of
neuroimaging with MRI
and PET scanning
technology, and then
the emergence of
molecular genetics,
and then the burgeoning
of neuroscience
as a discipline, which took
all the basic neuroscience
approaches and focused
them on the brain.
Psychiatry was sort
of catapulted forward.
So here I was in medical
school in the 1970s, when
all this really was converging
and moving the field forward
out of the kind of
intellectual wasteland
where it had been without
any real understanding,
and beyond what had been
the kind of domination
of psychiatry by
Freudian theory.
And I'll come back
to Freud in a minute.
So in medical
school, I was there
when this all began to happen.
And in the course of
my three-decade career
I was able to see and
participate in the evolution
as it occurred.
So it put me in a position to
not just describe a history
and not just punctuated with
clinical case histories,
but also to provide an
autobiographical prospective.
Another thing that I thought
was really, I guess, fitting
was the fact that if
one were to look over
the 200-year trajectory
of psychiatry,
there has been, in its
effort to try and achieve
an understanding of the basis of
mental illness and development
of treatments, a kind
of an oscillation
between the biologic and the
metaphysical, or psychodynamic.
So when psychiatry sort
of emerged, treatment
of mental illness
began to be taken
as a medical sort of
mandate, the notion
was simply providing
a supportive,
protective environment for
people with mental illness.
And this was a
psychiatrist, a doctor
named Philippe Pinel, who really
created asylums and unlocked
the chains of people who
were in mental institutions.
But then in the 19th century
when medicine overall
was beginning a
systematic investigation,
the process really
consisted mostly
of anatomic pathology--
cadavers, organs,
looking for the pathologic bases
for illness-- a focus on this.
But this was a fruitless effort.
And then entered Freud.
And Freud came about in
the late 19th century
when psychiatry had not
been able to benefit
by the scientific
efforts, and he came up
with this brilliant theory,
this incredible tour de force.
His invention of the
psychoanalytic theory
was the equivalent
intellectually
and scientifically speaking
of Einstein's theory
of relativity, or Copernicus
and Galileo's heliocentrism.
He by dint of his intellectual
genius was able to do this.
And that moved psychiatry
back into the psychodynamic,
metaphysical, because
there was no tangible bases
for the illnesses.
The problem is that this
became something which
Freud made two mistakes with.
One was that he forbid
scientific investigation
to verify it, so it
remained basically a theory
that you had to accept on faith.
And then his disciples,
the neo-Freudians
began to expand it way
beyond the scope for which it
genuinely was valid
and could apply,
which was an understanding
of how the human mind evolves
over the life cycle
and how it functions.
And Freud introduced seminal
concepts that still are valid
today and have really been
given new life in the context
of cognitive neuroscience.
He introduced the concept of the
consciousness and unconscious.
Before that,
everybody thought they
knew everything that
was in their mind
and governed their behavior.
He introduced the idea
of somebody evolving
over stages of development.
He a little overemphasized
the sexual dimension of that,
but it was still an evolution
of stages across the life cycle.
He introduced the concept
of components of the mind--
id, ego, super ego.
He described defense mechanisms
as a way of which we somehow
cope with our conflicts
and emotional, distressing
feelings-- rationalization,
sublimation, denial,
projection.
So he was a genius,
but he restricted
any type of experimentation,
any tampering with the method,
and it became a faith, a
dogma, that really constrained
all of psychiatry
up until the 1950s
with the real beginning of
the scientific revolution.
So scientific
revolution-- and I just
told you it stemmed from
psychopharmacology and then
imaging and genetics and
neuroscience-- kind of shifted
the pendulum back towards
the emphasis on the biologic.
And there was a chairman
of psychiatry at Yale
in the 1970s named
Morton Reiser,
and he ruefully
commented at the time.
He said, for the last
50-some years psychiatry has
been brainless, and now
we're moving towards a state
where we're going
to be mindless.
So there's been
this oscillation.
And in terms of my
own sort of evolution,
the reason why I thought
it was somehow fitting
was because, being
a good Jewish son,
I guess I was always sort
of feeling some pressure
to become a doctor, but not
necessarily a psychiatrist.
But then when I went
to college and I
started reading in my
introductory psychology course
Freud, I was really struck
by the power of his theory.
In addition to being
a genius he was also
a brilliant communicator.
He wrote extremely well,
and when you read it,
it becomes just enthralling.
But the same time,
I also was going
to school-- I'm dating
myself-- in the 1960s, which
was a time of a lot of cultural
unrest and experimentation,
and so forth and so on.
So I did have some dabbling
in recreational drugs,
and I guess this is like the one
thing I might share in common
with Steven Jobs-- it certainly
isn't his financial success--
is that we both feel that
LSD was a very important sort
of experience to have.
But in my case I
think it's a little
different than in Steven's case.
In my case, the impact
that it had on me--
and this is after
I had read Freud
and I was really just completely
fascinated by his theory--
was how you could
take a tiny amount
of a pharmacologic substance--
50 micrograms or so--
and you could so profoundly
change your state of mind.
And if this was the case,
then by some slight error
in an enzyme or a
cofactor or synthesis
of a neurotransmitter,
you could change
the way a person's mental
state was very powerfully.
So this sort of exemplified
this kind of dichotomy,
which really is the essence of
psychiatry and mental illness,
which is on one hand clearly
reducible to neurobiology
but at the same time also
reflects the ephemeral
and the existential.
So I proceeded to
write the book.
And the book-- which I
hope you take a look at,
because I write in a
turgid academic prose,
but my editor and the
person who helped me
with the writing, [INAUDIBLE],
sort of beat me up.
And I think we've made it really
an interesting and entertaining
book that flows.
The book starts with a story,
and all the stories in the book
are about patients
that I've seen.
And they're all real.
They're just anonymized.
And it starts with a
story about I got visited
by a very famous person.
Obviously they're anonymized
and I'm won't even
tell you the profession
they were in,
but it's a household name.
And his wife came to see me
about their daughter, who
was 20 years old.
She had been at an
Ivy League school,
and she was having difficulty
and they had to pull her out.
And her difficulty was
her grades slipped,
her behavior was
weird, and she really
wasn't functioning
in the typical way.
And so they brought
her to see me.
But this was like three years
after she had been dropped out
of school, and in the
interim they had had her
seen by a motivational coach, a
self-esteem therapist, sent her
to a wilderness camp, had her
seen by various new age people.
And then one day
they were scared
by an incident that occurred.
The daughter was
supposed to meet
her mother in Manhattan for
lunch, and she didn't show up.
And it turns out she
had gotten on the subway
to go meet her mother, but some
sleazy guy kind of inveigled
her in getting off
the subway with him
and going back to his apartment.
So the mother was freaking
out, and she tracked her down
via her cellphone and
she called the police
and they rescued her.
And when she told their
family doctor about this,
the doctor says, well,
for Christ's sake
why don't you just take her
to see a real doctor finally?
So they did.
They came, and we did
a thorough evaluation.
And I told them, your
daughter is psychotic,
and I think the likelihood is
that she has schizophrenia.
You don't want to give
that news to anybody,
but they certainly
didn't want to hear.
But in any event, they
agreed to hospitalize her.
She was hospitalized.
She was treated.
She got better.
But they still
couldn't accept it.
They took her to the
hospital, and after following
the aftercare treatment
that we had arranged for her
they took her out of
treatment, and she of course
relapsed fairly soon.
The good news is
that ultimately,
through another means, was
treated, achieved remission
again, and ultimately was
able to resume her life,
get married, and pursue
her interest in art.
But it shows you the degree to
which people will not accept,
acknowledge this.
And I have numerous,
numerous stories about this.
One that I'll refer to
that is not in the book
but is relevant to
contemporary times
is that you're probably
familiar with this case that's
going on in the news
now with Robert Durst.
So Robert Durst--
pretty bizarre guy,
the scion of a very
wealthy real estate family.
And he allegedly killed at
least three people, if not more.
But he's been weird
his whole life.
He's 71.
And then he agreed
to be a subject
of a biopic documentary.
And not being aware of it,
he was wearing a live mic
when he went to the bathroom
at the end of the last episode,
and he basically confessed
talking to himself.
Well, this is
speculation, but I think
that it's very likely
he was mentally ill
and probably suffered
from a psychotic illness,
and when he was talking he was
actually talking to voices.
But he had gone 70 years without
ever being treated for this
or evaluated, probably in
part because he was rich
and considered eccentric.
In this way, it's sort
of like John Du Pont, who
was the character in
"Foxcatcher" who also had
a similar pattern
of bizarre behavior,
undiagnosed schizophrenia,
and ended up
killing this Olympic athlete
that he had sponsored.
So the book opens with an
explanation of how there still
is the sort of massive denial.
Again referring to
Steven Jobs, Steve,
who believed in a lot of
holistic types of practices,
delayed his conventional
medical treatment in favor
of a holistic fashion, and
that not only didn't work,
it may have also
allowed for his illness
to progress to a point
that was uncurable.
So these attitudes sort
of still prevail and limit
people in terms of
seeking treatment.
But the other thing
that the book tries
to do in order to be
able to dispel the stigma
and persuade people
that there are
effective treatments for
people of mental illness
and that mental illness
is a bona fide set
of medical conditions
is that it tries
to fess up about the problems
that have occurred in the past
and why there is such skepticism
or suspicion or hostility
towards psychiatry.
It's true psychiatry did
some good some bad things.
We know about the
fact that first
of all, mental
institutions-- asylums--
weren't necessarily
the best places.
But beyond that,
there were treatments
that were either
ineffective or in some cases
seeming in retrospect
to have been barbaric.
The first Nobel
Prize that was ever
given for a treatment
for mental illness
or for anything
related to psychiatry
was given to an
Austrian psychiatrist
for malaria therapy.
So malaria therapy was
injecting the blood
of people who had malaria
into mental patients.
And the reason
that that was done
was that the
doctor-- and this was
circa 1920-- had observed that
when patients in his asylum
became febrile, their
symptoms seemed to improve.
And he thought that
fever must have
some kind of therapeutic
effect, so he
thought to induce fever
by injecting various types
of infectious agents.
So first he started
with strep, and then
the tubercular bacilliaie.
But then he tried malaria.
Why malaria?
Because antibiotics
hadn't been developed yet.
There was nothing
for tuberculosis,
but for malaria
there was quinine.
So can infect him
with malaria and get
the therapeutic
benefit, if it had that,
for their mental problems,
but he could also
control their somatic
symptoms with quinine.
And he got a Nobel
Prize for that.
Well, it turned out
that he was right.
But only partially, because
what that did-- the fever caused
by the malaria-- was
to kill spirochetes
in the brain of people
who had tertiary syphilis.
Because mental
institutions at the time,
in addition to people with
schizophrenia and bipolar
disorder, had a
lot of people that
had syphilis that had
progressed to enter the brain
and produce the tertiary
stage and produce symptoms
which look like psychosis.
And the next Nobel Prize
that was given for psychiatry
was to the Portuguese
neurologist Moniz
for developing the prefrontal
leucotomy-- lobotomies.
This sounds pretty gruesome,
and it is in retrospect.
But in defense of our profession
and these people, at the time--
and this is sort of like
trying to avoid us being guilty
of presenteeism, your
looking at the past
through the lens of
2015-- the alternative
was the abysmal
conditions of the asylum
and a life of potentially
continuing symptoms.
So this shows you
the desperation
that people were going to.
But then Freud
again, although he
did have this brilliant
theory, his disciples
extended it and
over-applied it in ways
that added to the ignominy
of the profession.
And this brings us to the point
where the neo-Freudians-- so
if anybody wants to know,
what is psychoanalytic theory
relevant to?
It's relevant to you and me and
everyone else that ostensibly
is free of a mental illness.
It is relevant to
understanding how
our psychological makeup and
our identity and personality
developed.
And psychoanalysis is useful
for people for self-exploration,
or for finding out how you can
avoid certain conflicts that
may occur in your life--
whether it's you don't get along
with your boss or you have
no gratifying romantic
relationships or you're engaging
in self-defeating behavior,
so forth-- but it's not going
to do anything for somebody
who has schizophrenia.
It's not going to do
anything for somebody
who has bipolar
disorder or depression
or obsessive compulsive
disorder or panic
disorder or an eating disorder
or an addiction or autism
or dementia.
But the neo-Freudians
tried to apply it
to this, and as a
result who gets blamed?
The mother.
Frieda Fromm- Reichmann
who was the psychiatrist
in the well-known book "I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden"
coined the term
"schizophrenogenic mother,"
because mothers who
engage in some kind
of confusing, contradictory,
overly critical behavior
can induce this.
When autism was finally
described in 1943
they coined the term
"refrigerator mother"
as the basis for autism.
And then there is, of
course, the other things
such as penis envy and
the oedipal complex
and all of these things.
So this sort of added
to the suspicion
and querulousness that
people had about psychiatry.
So you had illnesses
that nothing could work,
and then you had
doctors that came up
with these sort of fanciful
theories and treatments
that were either
ineffective or harmful.
And this created a legacy
which bore, or gave rise to,
the bad reputation and the
kind of notorious identity
of the profession.
But then as I've said, in
the '50s it begin to change,
first serendipitously
and then as a result
of these developments
in the life
sciences and
biomedical research.
And the change has been
extraordinary to the point
that now we have effective
treatments for most things.
Now, people say that
psychiatry is still
kind of an indolent,
ineffective profession,
but that's just a
bogus criticism.
It's just not true.
If you look at conditions
in, let's say, neurology,
our sibling discipline, three of
the major diseases-- they treat
Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson's disease,
Huntington's
disease-- are diseases
that there's an extensive
knowledge of the neurobiology.
With Huntington's we even
have the gene that causes it.
We've had it for
over two decades.
There's no treatment for it.
There's no effective treatment.
There's not been an innovation
in the treatment of Parkinson's
disease since L-DOPA.
Now, why is that?
So all this time
that psychiatry was
making these missteps and other
fields-- at least neurology--
was making progress--
but limited progress
with no treatments-- it wasn't
because they were slackers
or weren't smarter.
It wasn't the dumbest
kids in the class
were going into psychiatry.
The brain turns out to be a much
tougher organ to understand,
and the illnesses that affect
it much more complicated
to develop treatments for.
If you look at
the brain compared
to the heart, the lungs,
kidneys, there's no comparison.
The brain's like a pump,
the kidneys are a filter,
your stomach is a tube with
porous holes for absorption.
The brain has over
100 billion neurons.
30 trillion connections.
Each part of the brain
functions in a distinct way
from other parts of the brain.
It's unfathomably complex.
And the human brain is the
most highly-evolved structure
in the entire universe
in terms of organisms,
and the functions of the
brain that psychiatry attends
to for mental illness are
the most highly involved
in the entire animal kingdom.
So it's taken a long
time to really begin
to get traction on
that, and a lot of it
had to do with the availability
of the adequate technology
to do so.
So I guess just to
try and sum up, I
would say there are other
things that psychiatry
has done that have
also contributed
to the ignominy that mental
illness and psychiatry faces.
The unfortunate inclusion
of homosexuality
as a mental disorder is one.
Another was the lack
of inclusion of PTSD
until after Vietnam,
really, was another.
But there's been a purposeful
and a scientifically-driven
effort to correct these.
And the point this is that
whatever may have gone before,
which we can try and
understand and determine
how problematic it is or was,
that's not the reality now.
But it's the attitudes
and the prejudices
that persist which cloud
the public's understanding
and deter people from
seeking treatment.
And so the thing that I
want people to take away
from this book and that I
would like you to understand
is that there's no
reason that people
who suffer from conditions
should continue to.
It's simply a matter of
investing the time and money
that it takes to at least
have a consultation.
And there are treatments
that are effective.
And by treatments I'm not just
talking about medications.
I'm talking about various
types of psychotherapies
or psychosocial
treatments, as well.
But they're
scientifically-driven in terms
of determining their
efficacy and their safety.
So for you, for your
family, for your friends,
you should not be
inhibited by expressing
that you have nothing to
lose by at least exploring
whether there may be
a need for treatment.
The other thing is
that since so much
of the way any health care
service can be provided
is influenced by public
awareness and government
policy, the media and the
government need to be moved.
Left to their own
devices they're
not doing the right thing.
The media misrepresents,
sensationalizes, distorts.
And the government's policies
for biomedical research funding
and for providing health care
financing for mental health
care services, as opposed to
medical or surgical services,
is really not
consistent with what
the needs of people
with mental illness are
and what the whole
epidemiology is.
Just to give you
one last statistic,
The World Bank does a study
every several years measuring
the global burden of disease.
And they quantify this in
the context of a metric
they call the Disability
Associated Life Year, or DALY.
And if you look at youth 14 to
45, 4 of the top 10 conditions
are mental disorders.
It's predicted that
by 2030 depression
will be the most expensive
condition in the world,
so there's good reason for the
government to pay attention
to this public health issue.
And I think since left
to their own devices
they won't, to whatever
degree people who
have their awareness raised or
motivated, can help to do that.
And again, this goes back to
why I wanted to write the book.
When I tell people
about it I say,
well, it was sort of
a quixotic moment.
But we'll see if the
book gets any attention
and if it has any
impact on the world.
So if we have some time, I'd be
happy to answer any questions.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned some parts
of the body that are relatively
easier to treat than the brain.
So, knee surgery is
relatively straightforward,
hip surgery relatively
straightforward.
And the physicians who do
those types of treatments
maybe don't take the same kind
of flack that psychiatrists do.
I started to think about low
back pain as something that's
really common, just like
everybody has a mental illness,
everybody gets low back pain
at some point in their life.
And often, people will go to
a holistic type of practice,
or they'll go do various
physical therapies,
chiropractor.
But the extreme example would
be going to get back surgery,
kind of like the extreme
in psychology would be,
go see a psychiatrist.
And I think part of
the rap with back pain
is they say back
surgery, fusions,
things like that are
quite ineffective-- maybe
30% chance of success,
and they often
can lead to problems
down the line.
Would you say that maybe part of
the perception with psychiatry
is you only hear about those
cases where it doesn't work,
or when mistakes are made?
You don't hear the
success stories.
JEFFREY LIEBERMAN: I
think that's very true.
First of all, people
don't want to disclose,
even if they've had
a good experience.
They're more inclined
to lay blame.
So Katharine Graham, the former
publisher of The Washington
Post, had a several decade
long grudge against psychiatry.
Why?
Because her husband, who had
manic depressive illness,
was treated with psychoanalysis,
never given lithium,
and committed suicide.
That was a widely-known case.
But the success, such as the
famous person I told you about,
whose daughter was averted
from a lifelong disability--
if I call them and ask them,
would you talk at a benefit,
or would you be a
public spokesperson, no.
Don't want to hear about that.
That gets to the
kind of stigma thing.
Many patients won't use
their health insurance,
because they don't want
to be on the record.
Many patients-- and this
is particularly with
the VIP's-- they don't want to
come see me or see our doctors
in the hospital in the clinic.
They want to go to
a private office
on Park Avenue or
Central Park West
so they don't have to walk into
something that's psychiatry.
So this is a very
common phenomena.
It's changing.
And it's actually better
in the United States
than any part of the world.
I mean, Asia?
Forget it.
But it's still
going very slowly.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to press a
little bit on your assertion
that it's all about stigma--
that that's the principle
barrier-- because
it seems like access
is enormously challenging.
If you look at the
prevalence of mental illness
amongst the homeless or
amongst prison populations,
it's way out of
proportion with where
it is in other aspects
of the population.
Can you say that stigma is
stronger, say in the US,
than the access barriers and
just availability of treatment?
JEFFREY LIEBERMAN: I
completely agree with you.
Whether it's lack
of access or stigma,
they're both major
contributors to it.
But the lack of
access problem is
that there's not sufficient
providers and services
to take care of everybody
or to take care of everybody
in an affordable way.
And as a result, people that
might be seeking treatment
may not have an easy
time finding it.
If they pursue it, though,
most people should be able to.
The problem is-- and this is
a problem that contributes
to the homeless, as well as the
increasing numbers of people
with mental illness who are
in the criminal justice,
in the prison, system-- that
many people-- and this is
particularly for the
psychotic disorders,
or mood disorders
also-- who have
mental illnesses don't
think they're sick,
and they don't want treatment.
And our society is built
on personal autonomy,
individual liberty,
self-determination,
and we're very reluctant
to sort of impose something
on somebody against
their will unless they're
overtly dangerous.
So there's many people who,
even if they had ready access,
wouldn't seek treatment,
and their families
can't find a way
to persuade or even
coerce them into
treatment, and doctors
can't impose it unilaterally.
But you're absolutely right.
And one of the other
things that I think
is really problematic with
our health financing has
led to a situation where
psychiatrists have the lowest
percentage of accepting
insurance as opposed
to paying out-of-pocket.
And that's because of the
inequity of the reimbursements.
Patrick Kennedy and Senator
Edward Kennedy's Mental Health
Parity Act has begun to
sort of address that.
But this has been
passed as legislation
and has not been enforced yet,
so the insurance companies are
still doing what they
can get away with.
AUDIENCE: Piggybacking
on access,
you mentioned-- it's been my
experience that psychologists
and psychiatrists have a
much lower rate of accepting
insurance.
And you made the distinction
between psychologists
and psychiatrists and
counselors that psychiatrists
are primarily focused
on defined illnesses.
But it's been my
experience that there
are a lot of not just
psychologists but counselors
or whatever that try to treat
more severe mental illness--
maybe not schizophrenia,
but certainly depression
or bipolar disorder--
and that if I came in
with a twisted ankle
and I sought treatment.
Pretty quickly I could figure
out, oh, you go to the doctor.
And the first doctor I
went to would probably
be able to help me.
That is certainly not the case
as much with mental illness.
So I guess my question is,
what are your thoughts on how
to [INAUDIBLE]?
JEFFREY LIEBERMAN: That's
part of the confusion of,
OK, let's say you think
that you may have something
that needs to be taken care of.
Who do I see, and how
do I know who to go to?
And then there's the
access and the cost issue.
My rule of thumb is
that's psychiatrists
don't need to do anything.
You don't necessarily
need to pay a psychiatrist
to see you once or twice
a week for 45 minutes
to talk about your
inability to form
good romantic relationships
or why you can't get along
with authority figures.
Good, competent
therapists can do that.
But if you want to go to a
psychiatrist to make sure
there's nothing more serious
going on than just so
that, you can start
with a psychiatrist.
And what's evolving--
and this is
being driven by really economic
pressure, what insurance
benefits are willing to pay--
is that the psychiatrist
will make use of
physician extenders,
just like if you twist
your ankle and yo
go to an orthopedist.
They take an x-ray.
Maybe you broke it.
They set a cast.
But then they'll send
you a physical therapist.
Psychiatrists can
see you, say, OK, I
don't think that you have
personality disorder.
I don't think you have
a mood disorder that
requires treatment, but I think
psychotherapy would be good.
You can see me for it,
if he or she practices,
or I can ask you to see a social
worker or a psychologist that
would be perfectly
capable of seeing you.
There's going to be more
of this team-based approach
and this delegation of various
aspects of the treatment
recommendations.
The problem is this
is all coming so slow.
It's just not taken seriously.
Part of it is our government is
dysfunctional, and part of it
is because this hasn't risen to
a sufficient level of urgency.
Let me just give
you one example.
It takes a lot to mobilize
a government in a country.
The one thing that did
it, amazingly, was AIDS.
When I was in training
in the late '70s
we would see people coming
into the emergency room
with these horrible infections,
opportunistic infections.
There was no clear cause for it.
There was no sort
of etiologic agent.
They had low blood counts
and these roaring infections.
But the gay community, the
entertainment community,
rose up, and they
lobbied out-of-the-box
for the government
to jump on this.
And they poured money.
It was like a Manhattan
Project for this condition.
And within six years they
had identified the virus.
So it went from AIDS-- Acquired
Immune Deficiency Syndrome--
to HIV, Human
Immunodeficiency Virus.
And then within
another six years
they had protease inhibitors,
antiretroviral therapies--
and then the advent of
triple therapy, which
took a mysterious,
lethal disorder
and made it into a chronic
illness like hypertension
or diabetes that
could be managed.
So mental illness doesn't
have that kind of thing, OK?
So for depression, for
bipolar, for schizophrenia,
for anxiety disorders,
maybe you can't
mobilize that kind of thing.
But why haven't we
done this with PTSD?
I mean, if there's
one thing that you
think the country should
rally around-- particularly
since now more people die
by suicide in the military
than by enemy combatants, and
the frequency of PTSD injuries
is more than by any
type of somatic injury.
It's shameful.
So when I got into this
APA leadership thing
I spent two years in
Washington, and it
is a very cynical
business, the business
of politics and government.
And it's tough to change.
But this is really
what it takes.
And this is-- again, alluding
to my quixotic effort
to write this book-- a need to
try and really raise awareness,
speak out, try and
mobilize, because these
are tractable problems.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying
to better understand.
You made a distinction, I think,
between psychosis and neurosis,
although you didn't
identify it as such.
And you kind of say
psychiatry is about psychosis.
JEFFREY LIEBERMAN: No,
no, no, not psychosis.
Mental illness.
Psychosis and neurosis
is a distinction
that really hearkens back
to the earlier nomenclature
in Freudian theory.
I was equating
neurosis in the sense
with the kind of problems
of living that occur,
and mental illness
as a defined set
of conditions which
includes psychosis but isn't
exclusively psychosis.
AUDIENCE: And what distinguishes
PTSD from other form-- PTSD
is based on an experience--
not a childhood experience,
an adult experience-- that
shapes your interaction
with the environment.
How is this different
than other experiences,
and why do you find
this is mental illness
and other things are just for
psychologists to take care of?
This is confusing to me.
JEFFREY LIEBERMAN: Well, forget
about who takes care of them.
I would think
anybody who can get
them better should take care.
But why is PTSD an illness?
Well, somebody undergoes
some kind of experience.
It's usually a single,
traumatic event,
but it can be a series
of traumatic events--
whether it's an earthquake, a
fire, a mugging, a firefight
in Afghanistan or
in IED explosion--
and prior to that they were
ostensibly not ill, or healthy.
And subsequent to
that they begin
to develop a variety of mental
aberrations and behaviors--
anxiety, hypervigilance,
sleeplessness, irritability,
inability to concentrate.
It sometimes leads them to
do things like abuse alcohol
or other medications,
to self-medicate, or get
into violent altercations.
And this doesn't just go
away like you bump your knee
and after a few days
the pain subsides.
This persists.
So here you have environmental
or experiential event
which results in some enduring
pattern of mental distress
and behavioral dysfunction.
So what we call that an illness.
As to who should
treat it, I think
right now our
treatments are very
limited in terms of what works.
And the problem there is that
sufficient attention-- I mean,
PTSD is not a new condition.
It's been around since
the history of warfare,
but we didn't take it
seriously until after Vietnam.
But there wasn't
an all-out effort
to try and understand, what is
the pathophysiology of this?
How does an experience
affect the brain
so that you're
thereafter different?
If it turns out that the best
way to treat somebody like that
is through horseback riding
or pet therapy or exercise
or meditation or psychotherapy
or aversion conditioning, fine.
But if it turns out that it's
medication, that's fine too.
We just have to understand
what it is that's needed.
But I would consider
it an illness
beyond a shadow of doubt.
AUDIENCE: I remember
a couple years ago
we had a lot of
unfortunate incidents--
tragedies-- in America
with school shootings.
And I remember the most
poignant thing that
came for me for
that was a mother
wrote an article
or story about how
she had three
children-- two of which
were healthy, normal-- but one
was very violent and, I guess,
obviously mentally
ill and would have
episodes that would go grab
a knife maybe in the kitchen.
No crime yet, but she knew
and felt something was coming.
And law enforcement says to her,
he hasn't done anything yet.
We can't do anything for you.
You can just send him
to the institution
and see what happens.
Often I think parents
take the blame.
How could you not know your
kid was going to do this?
And she knows, but didn't
have an outlet or an option.
And it's tragic.
Do you have any hope for
America, for the world,
for how that can get better?
JEFFREY LIEBERMAN: So that was,
"I am Adam Lanza's Mother."
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
JEFFREY LIEBERMAN: This was
after the Newtown tragedy,
where Adam Lanza
killed these kids.
And his mother, I think, who was
in Idaho, wrote this article.
So it really relates to how
do you deal with a situation
where there's a family member
or friend whatever who's
sick, potentially violent,
doesn't want treatment,
and you can't force them
to receive treatment.
And the majority of
these civilian massacres
that have occurred-- whether
it's when congressman Gabby
Giffords was shot, whether
it was in rural Colorado,
whether it was the Virginia
Tech shooting, whether it was
the Santa Barbara killing--
are not entirely-- sometimes
you have ideological
zealots, but these
are predominately individuals
with mental illness
who are untreated.
So Robert Durst--
I'm suggesting he
may be like that, although he
didn't do a civilian massacre.
He just killed one
people individually
over a period of time.
I was doing a reading at
a bookstore last night,
and afterwards
when I was signing
books a woman came up to me
and told me she was Iranian.
Lives in San Francisco.
And says, I wonder
if you could help me.
I said, what's the problem?
She says, I have a brother
who has schizophrenia.
He's in Iran.
And he killed my mother,
and he's now in prison.
Is there something I can do?
So you see this intrafamily
violence all the time.
These people don't know
what they're doing.
But there's no
means to treat them.
When I was at University
of North Carolina
there was a law student
who in his first year
became psychotic, had a first
episode of schizophrenia.
And we hospitalized him.
He was treated.
He got better.
The symptom remission
was very high,
particularly at the
beginning of the illness.
Went home for the summer.
Stopped his medication.
Came back to school.
Unfortunately the
law school and we
didn't sort of
identify and require
him to resume treatment--
not that we could have,
at least not if he
didn't want it anyway.
And three months
later he walks down
the main street of Chapel
Hill and he kills two people--
two complete
strangers-- because he
was hallucinating about what
they were thinking and saying
about him.
He was found not guilty
by reason of insanity,
remanded to a state
mental hospital,
and I interviewed
him because he had
wanted to write a book
about this experience.
His name is Wendell Williamson.
And he was completely
lucid, had complete insight
into what was happening.
He said, I had no idea.
The internal reality of my
delusions and hallucinations
were as vivid as everything
that's in this room around us.
But this is something
that goes beyond science,
goes beyond medicine.
This is a social policy issue.
And if I say this
in a large audience,
I get a lot of angry comments
and sometimes even hate mail.
If you suggest the idea
of imposing treatment
on people when
they don't want it,
there's a strong
reaction to that.
And it's because in the
past treatments were imposed
on people, either
unjustifiably or the treatments
were ineffective.
But this is the dilemma.
But I advocate
what I call sort of
maternalistic or
paternalistic medicine,
that if people are making
judgments that are not--
I mean, if you're a
Christian Scientist
and you don't want treatment
for your cancer or your heart
disease and you want
to die, that's fine.
But mental illness is
a little different.
It's like if you
have tuberculosis
and you don't want
to get treated,
and you're a contagion.
Or AIDS.
So there's some
social ramifications
to giving people-- to
emphasize elevating
the rights of the individual
over the welfare of society,
and that's above my pay grade.
Thank you for the answer.
And I think we're at time,
but there's books in the back.
Thank you, Dr. Lieberman.
[APPLAUSE]